this morning we hear from former vice
president Mike Pence he's on the road
spelling out his vision for America's
future while many wonder if he will
challenge former president Trump for the
2024 GOP nomination Pence spoke with our
Robert Costa yesterday during a book
tour stop in Central Florida they
discussed many issues home and abroad
including the recent political violence
in Brazil and Pence did not rule out a
presidential campaign Robert Costa joins
us now Robert good morning
good morning Nate from the villages in
Central Florida a republican stronghold
and retirement community we sat down
with former vice president Mike Pence
top of mind for him was another former
vice president President Joe Biden and
his handling of documents marked as
classified following the CBS news report
earlier this week
do you approve of how the justice
department has handled this matter so
far no I don't approve how the justice
department has handled this matter and I
don't approve how they handle the matter
of classified documents found
at Mar-A-Lago former vice president Mike
Pence offered sharp criticism of the
justice department where a special
counsel is now probing how his former
boss former president Donald Trump
handled records marked as classified the
kind of double standard that we see
being practiced by the Biden
Administration in in the wake of this
incident in the Justice Department I
think it's exactly what undermines
public confidence
in our justice system Biden's lawyer and
the White House have said the
president's team dealt swiftly with the
discovered records but Republicans like
Penn say the current review of the
materials by a U.S attorney might not be
enough would you like to see a special
counsel or not for the Biden papers I
think the Biden paper should be dealt
with precisely the same way
the president Trump's papers have been
dealt with and examined with the same
thoroughness and carefulness but would
you acknowledge these aren't equal
episodes I would say Bob they're
different in degree but not in kind
two years after the attack on the
capitol where he oversaw the
Congressional certification Pence
reflected on challenges to democracy
both here and abroad
including recent riots in Brazil amid
false accusations of a stolen election
there it is evidence that what happens
in the United States has repercussions
around the world I I have no doubt that
that tragic day in January of 2021 in
this country played some role in sowing
the seeds of what's taking place in
Brazil despite tensions with Trump Pence
continues to move closer to a 2024 bid
where winning over Trump voters might be
key how close are you to a final
decision on a 2024 run the truth is that
I think I think we've got time people
around America know the pences so we're
going to take the opportunity that time
and we're going to continue to listen
we're going to continue to pray and I
promise to keep you posted
Pence is soon going to launch a tour of
mega churches underscoring his courting
of conservative Evangelical voters and
he was courting them yesterday here in
Florida the backyard not only of former
president Trump but another possible
2024 presidential rival Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis
it seems a lot of people are interested
in the job Bob before you go we know
Republicans are in control of the house
and now they voted to create a special
committee to investigate federal law
enforcement agencies so what more if
anything can you tell us about that
Gail this was a vote that was held on a
party line it's for what Republicans say
is an attempt to investigate the
weaponization of government it will be a
subcommittee chaired by Jim Jordan the
Ohio Republican a key Trump Ally and it
will have subpoena power to look into
the FBI in the CIA this was a
subcommittee that was part of the
discussions that made Kevin McCarthy the
speaker of the house also fueled by long
grievances inside the Republican Party
about investigations of former president
Trump Gail
I know you're on top of it thank you Bob
always good to see you in the morning
thanks